[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here with a
pretty random off the cuff video not
exactly highly edited or anything at all
but i just kind of wanted to talk to you
guys so if you like that kind of style
let me know uh but basically i was
trying to think of like what the next
big thing in mobile phones anyway would
be as you've noticed it's kind of come
in sort of waves every year at ces which
is in january we see what the focus is
on i remember when the focus of ces was
3d and that turned up to start in
happening in mobile phones and that was
bad but ever since the iphone 4 that
next big thing which seems to be i mean
that's samsung's tagline for the galaxy
s3 but the next big thing was having the
highest resolution highest dpi display
possible so the iphone 4 was introduced
i guess two and a half years ago now in
the middle of 2010 and that had a 960 by
640 retina display and we've always seen
that when apple does something that's
really impressive other companies try to
want or tend to want to at least imitate
or better that feature so ever since
then we've seen manufacturers come out
with insanely high resolution displays
we saw the first wave of 720p hd
smartphones so we saw you know super
amoled displays with 1280 by 720
resolutions we saw the galaxy s3 we saw
phones with 1280 by 800 resolutions and
even higher than that so we're starting
to roll around to the next year at ces
and we're gonna find out what this next
big focus or push is but i've kind of
wanted it and maybe you agree maybe you
don't but i feel like i've wanted the
next big thing to be battery life
battery technology batteries and mobile
devices need to be the next big thing
that's innovative we see now the htc uh
droid dna with a 1080p smartphone 1080p
display uh also the oppo fine 5 is
coming to the united states with a
1920x1080 resolution the nexus 10 tablet
has a 2560 by 1600 resolution same one
as that display right there but the
problem is content isn't exactly
optimized so we've gone past our
software with our hardware already and
we've seen a lot of displays now that
make us go wow you know the samsung
galaxy s3 display is a wow display the
note 2 is a wow display the dna is a wow
display the htc one x is a wow display
the nexus 4 is a wow display nexus 10 is
a wow display when's the last time you
saw a phone with a wow battery life
i haven't in a while there hasn't been a
phone maybe a little bit of a push and i
kind of had a glimmer of hope with
phones like the droid razer max and the
galaxy note 2. these are two phones that
actually have really big batteries and
somewhat impressive wow battery life but
i
personally would really like the next
big push the next big wave in mobile
technology as far as tablets and
smartphones go to be battery life
because that's really what's needed help
i did a rant a really long time ago
about battery technology and has it
hasn't moved forward in a really long
time if i'm feeling daring i might put
that link below but it's a really old
video so it might not be great but
anyway
go ahead and leave a thumbs up on this
video if you agree but i definitely
think that the next big push
that would really sell people because i
hear people complaining about battery
life all the time
the next big push the next big thing
should be battery life so uh yeah let me
know what you guys think down in the
comment section below again this is just
a random
totally unedited video i just felt like
telling you guys and letting you guys
know and getting your thoughts and maybe
there will be some conversation in the
comments section below and feel free to
give a thumbs up on your favorite
comments to get them viewed and uh we'll
have conversation either way thanks for
watching oh feel free to stay tuned also
because there are some awesome videos
coming up on the channel especially uh
we're at the holiday season now so
there's going to be some holiday themed
videos giveaways and also some fun
contests and stuff so
yeah thanks for watching and i'll talk
to you guys in the next one peace
[Music]
you